c'est un colosse de 450 m de long 22
mètres de hauteur et dont la contenance
et 2 5 millions 200 mille mètres cubes
mais un colosse aux pieds d'argile
car les fondations de cet ouvrage vieux
de cent quatre-vingt-onze ans était
fragilisé le barrage en lui même est
très solide c'est un gros barrages en
moins 20 degrés mais qui était posée en
fait sur une couche un peu marneuses et
glissante ce qui fait que la force de
l'eau poucet avait tendance à faire
basculer le barrage par le fonds après
la vidange totale du barrage commencé en
octobre 2019
les travaux ont débuté en février 2020
du béton a été injecté dans les
fondations des fissures ont été
consolidées en prévention des crues au
point le plus bas du barrage cette vanne
de secours laisse désormais passé dix
sept mètres cubes seconde et sept
évacuateur 50 mètres cubes/seconde des
travaux de sécurisation et de
modernisation on a aussi fait de la
modernisation par des dispositifs
d'auscultation sur lequel on a plusieurs
types qu'ils sont automatisées et qui
sont tous centralisé dans un local
technique et aussi en termes de gestion
hydraulique ce qui nous permet de savoir
les entrants et les sortants au niveau
du barrage
ce qui nous donne de bonnes données par
rapport à la meilleure gestion de l'eau
une gestion de l'eau assurée par voies
navigables de france propriétaire et
gestionnaire des six barrages réservoirs
qui alimentent le canal de bourgogne
construit pour relier la somme et la
scène ses stocks d'eau apporte
énormément de fonctionnalités au
territoire
ils permettent d'apporter de l'eau au
canal ils permettent de préserver de la
biodiversité ils font vraiment partie
intégrante du territoire et surtout ils
permettent en fait de il permettre la
navigation sur le canal de bourgogne la
navigation à ce canal de bourgogne c'est
13 millions d'euros de retombées
socioéconomiques parents la cote
d'exploitation du brunch c'est la ligne
en bas des herbes au jaune qu'on voit là
donc ça sera la cote de 16 mètres quand
le barrage se remplira de nouveau il
faudra un an
le remplissage est en liées à la pluie
au métro